hey you dirty Birds think story here
with our episode 8 breakdown and
although this episode was quite short it
was filled with a lot of action not a
lot of huge development since last
week's return of the kid but I think
things are really ramping up for the
final two episodes so let's get right
into this breakdown last episode Annie
and joy were taken into police custody
but little do they know the cop that
picked her up is on aces side they're
dropped off at the Marston home which
will turn out to be even worse than the
precinct meanwhile the townspeople amass
around the statue of the kid and as
we'll find out later they're working
their way towards the Marston home
gathering more followers as they go
according to the patient that Nadia
talks to at the hospital everyone heard
a noise that called them towards the
statue I'm still not sure why this noise
is affecting some people and not others
and here's a fun little Easter egg of
directions to Jerusalem's lot and Derry
back of the Marsten's we see ace replace
Annie's pills with placebos remember
that antipsychotics screw up their hold
over the vessels so if they're gonna use
Annie they need her free from the meds
annie has totally creeped out by this
place not only is it run by ACE the man
she killed with an ice cream scoop in
episode 1 it's also where she emerged
and saw two people messing around back
in episode 2 this is also where she'll
begin hearing voices and it's not the
skismo or the voices compelling the
townspeople it's of her mother the same
one who tried killing the both of them
years ago it seems being off these meds
bring her mother out the mother wants
her to kill joy in an effort to make her
clean we get a glimpse of Chris and
Valerie looking at one of the paintings
with several buildings on fire we can
assume this is a portrait of what's to
come in the future
remember last episode we saw this
ominous painting of an angel overlooking
a burning city likely Castle Rock the
French spirits have cut off
communication with the outside world
Nadia can't even get reception on her
phone she's visited by Chris who's under
the control of a spirit named Bertrand
who attacks her but Nadia's stethoscope
powers are too strong back at the
Marston home Valerie and covers a series
of joys drawings depicting a woman
trying to save another over the side of
a cliff the first thing we notice is the
style of drawing is much like a matiz
this revelation
later makes a stink joy not Annie is the
better vessel after all she is clean and
undefiled by poisons and drugs remember
way back in episode three that joy heard
the skismo
on Castle Lake when no one else did
meaning that she liked Amity and Henry
Deaver last season are in tune with it
the pitcher is most likely that of any
trying to save joy over the cliffs at
Castle Lake the same cliff where Amity
found the kid and where Henry Deaver
pushed his dad in the film misery
there's no mention of joy suggesting
that this may be where joy dies at the
end of the season they're also wearing
period clothing likely from the 1600s
now I doubt they'll be going back in
time but my best guess is that during
aces ceremony they'll be fitted with
clothes from the 1600s the other odd
aspect of the pitcher are the legs
either it's a stylistic choice and it
doesn't really mean anything or it's
referencing that this person is not
exactly human that there may be a more
supernatural element at play at the
hospital Nadia gives Chris a shot of
Haldol which briefly allows the real
Chris to come back to consciousness
warning Nadia that they're coming for
her annie is haunted yet again by her
mother when she experiences
hallucinations including this cool
jump-scare where water bursts from the
mirror fitting since her mother drowned
joy is captured by ace and any stumbles
upon a mass of dead bodies in the
Marston basement now we don't really
know if this is where they're storing
these bodies or if they'll be used for
some other purpose later on back at the
hospital we get a glimpse of the man who
has taken over Chris's body two of aces
thugs come chasing after them but Nadia
is able to lock herself in the medicine
storage and using Chris to fool them
take them down but not without losing
Chris who's shot in the skirmish his
final words were I always but he doesn't
have chance to finish his sentence my
guess is that he wanted to say I always
loved you
Annie searches for joy attacking Helen
getting stabbed in the shoulder and
using a sledgehammer just like she later
used in misery when she eventually finds
joy in the Attic visions of her mother
coax her into killing joy but she
overcomes this venturing out of the
house where all the townspeople have
congregated as they make their escape
the crowd suddenly begins to move and
lost in the shuffle accidentally locking
eyes with the statue which puts her
under its control that's basically the
episode nothing too major aside from the
reveal that joy will be taking over as
the vessel I'm hoping the next two
episodes provide us with more answers as
there are still a ton of mysteries that
have yet to be solved thanks for tuning
in I hope you'll give this video a like
and subscribe for more castle rock
videos and leave your thoughts and
theories about the show below you can
also follow me on Twitter at pings story
YT until next time remember daddy loves
you very much